♪ ♪
>> HE INITIATED A MAJOR LITERACY
PROGRAM -- YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK TEACHING PEOPLE TO READ
AND WRITE IS A GOOD THING.
THE TRUTH IS THE TRUTH.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
FIRST YEARS OF THE CASTRO
REGIME.
>> IT’S WHAT HE BELIEVES AND
THAT’S UNACCEPTABLE TO OUR
COMMUNITY, IT’S UNACCEPTABLE TO
ANYONE IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> DOESN’T DISQUALIFY HIM TO BE
PRESIDENT?
>> THAT’S FOR THE VOTERS TO
DECIDE BUT AS FAR AS I’M
CONCERNED, HE’S WAY OFF.
>> Bret: DEMOCRATS IN
SOUTH FLORIDA DON’T MUCH LIKE
THE LITERACY PROGRAM OF FIDEL
CASTRO OR THAT BERNIE SANDERS
BRINGS IT UP BUT BERNIE SANDERS
IS THE FRONT RUNNER OF THIS RACE
AND HE WILL BE UNDER ATTACK ON
THAT DEBATE STAGE, SEVEN
CANDIDATES AS YOU LOOK FROM
JOE BIDEN, MIKE BLOOMBERG,
PETE BUTTIGIEG, AMY KLOBUCHAR,
ELIZABETH WARREN, TOM STEYER.
VANITY FAIR A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
HAD A PIECE, "EVERYTHING ABOUT
SANDERS IS THAT HIS STUBBORN
DOGMA, HIS SOMETIMES KOOKY
SUPPORTERS, HIS CONTEMPT FOR
GREENROOM CULTURE AND PARTY
CIRCUIT IS COMPLETELY FOREIGN TO
THE INTELLECTUAL AND CULTURAL
FABRIC OF WASHINGTON.
IN THAT UNIT FORCE THE CLAIM
THAT HE IS UNELECTABLE IS MORE
OR LESS GOSPEL.
SOME TRUMP ADVISORS ARE WORRIED
ABOUT HIS STRENGTHS, HIS
POPULIST APPEAL, PERCEIVED
AUTHENTICITY, HIS DURABLE
POPULARITY WITH THE SAME WHITE
NONCOLLEGE VOTERS WHO VOTED FOR
TRUMP.
DEMOCRATS FRETTING ABOUT THE
PROSPECT OF NOMINATING SANDERS
SHOULD CONSIDER FOR A MOMENT HOW
A FEW YEARS IN AMERICAN POLITICS
HAVE EXPOSED THE FRAILTY OF
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM AND
INCREMENTAL THINKING.
THEY MIGHT ALSO CONSIDER A XANAX
INSTEAD OF ASKING IF SANDERS IS
UNELECTABLE, ASK ANOTHER
QUESTION.
WHAT IF SANDERS IS ACTUALLY THE
MOST ELECTABLE DEMOCRAT?
IN THE AGE OF TRUMP,
HYPERPARTISANSHIP, INSTITUTIONAL
DISTRUST, AND SOCIAL MEDIA,
SANDERS COULD BE EXAMINED AS A
CANDIDATE ALMOST CUSTOM-BUILT GO
HEAD-TO-HEAD WITH TRUMP THIS
YEAR."
IT WAS A FEW WEEKS AGO BEFORE HE
WENT ON A ROLL.
CHARLES HURT OPINION EDITOR OF
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES","
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
GEORGETOWN INSTITUTE OF POLITICS
AND JONAH GOLDBERG.
>> HE’S ONTO SOMETHING HERE, I
THINK BERNIE SANDERS IS GOING TO
HAVE A UNIQUE SET OF CHALLENGES
SHOULD HE BE THE NOMINEE BUT I
DON’T DISAGREE WITH PETER THAT
WE ARE IN A DIFFERENT ERA.
ONE OF THE WAYS DONALD TRUMP WON
WAS BY TAPPING INTO A SENSE OF
GRIEVANCE AMONG A WHOLE LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE, A POPULIST
SENSE OF GRIEVANCE AND USING
THAT TO TURN OUT VOTERS THAT WE
HAVEN’T SEEN YET.
THAT IS THE RATIONALE OF THE
SANDERS CAMPAIGN, THEY CAN TAP
INTO A POPULIST SENSE OF
GRIEVANCE AND TURN OUT A WHOLE
NEW GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THE FIRST THREE STATES WE
HAVEN’T SEEN HIM DO THAT, HE
HASN’T EXPANDED THE ELECTORATE
IN THE FIRST THREE STATES AND I
THINK COMMENTS LIKE THAT ONE ON
THE LITERACY PROGRAM IN CUBA
MIGHT BE A CHALLENGE IN SOME
PLACES.
WHAT DO ANY OF US KNOW?
WE WERE ALL SAYING THERE’S NO
WAY DONALD TRUMP CAN WIN FOUR
YEARS AGO AND HE PROVED US WRONG
WRONG.
>> Bret: JOE BIDEN IS IN A
POSITION IN SOUTH CAROLINA WHERE
HE REALLY NEEDS A WIN.
HE IS RUNNING AN AD AGAINST
BERNIE THAT’S RUNNING IN
SOUTH CAROLINA RIGHT NOW.
>> BERNIE SANDERS TOLD FELLOW
SENATORS HE WOULD TAKE ON OBAMA,
WHEN IT COMES TO BUILDING ON
PRESIDENT OBAMA’S LEGACY,
BERNIE SANDERS CAN’T BE TRUSTED.
>> Bret: THE QUESTION IS HOW
JOE BIDEN CAN BE TRUSTED ON THE
DEBATE STAGE?
’S PREVIOUS PERFORMANCE AND WHAT
TONIGHT COULD BRING.
>> EVERYONE IS GOING TO EMPTY
OUT THE STOREHOUSE OF AMMO ON
EVERYBODY I THINK.
THE BASIC PROBLEM WITH BIDEN IS
HE INCREASINGLY SOUNDS LIKE ONE
OF THOSE BAD LIPREADING VIDEOS
YOU SEE ON THE INTERNET WHERE
WORDS THAT DO NOT GO CORRECTLY
IN THE ORDER IN WHICH HE SANG
THEM COMES OUT OF HIS MOUTH WITH
ALARMING FREQUENCY.
>> Bret: TODAY WITH RUNNING
FOR THE U.S. SENATE.
>> HE’S TALKING ABOUT GETTING
ARRESTED VISITING NELSON MANDELA
NELSON MANDELA.
WHERE IS THE NURSE TO REIN HIM
IN?
THAT IS HIS REAL PROBLEM, IF HE
CAN COME OUT AND REASSURE PEOPLE
WITH MORE THAN SHOUTING AND
ANGER THAT HE WAS FULLY IN
CONTROL OF HIMSELF, I THINK HE
WOULD BE IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION BUT THERE’S A NERVOUS
MAKING ASPECT TO HIS CANDIDACY
AT THIS POINT, MAYBE HE CAN’T GO
THE DISTANCE.
>> Bret: HERE IS
BERNIE SANDERS ON "60 MINUTES"."
>> WHAT DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISM IS
ABOUT IS LET’S USE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT THE
INTEREST OF WORKING FAMILIES.
>> ANYBODY WHO REFERS TO
THEMSELVES AS A DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST, THAT WORD HAS ALWAYS
HAD REALLY DIRE CONSEQUENCES
THROUGHOUT SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> Bret: USUALLY ENDORMENTS
DON’T MEAN ALLOTMENT
REPRESENTATIVE CLYBURN’S
ENDORSEMENT MEANS A LOT AND IF
HE DOES PULL THE TRIGGER FOR
BIDEN AND GETS BEHIND HIM, MAYBE
THAT MOVES THEM ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
>> THE NONENDORSEMENTS LIKE --
WHAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING AND MIKE
BLOOMBERG, WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING ABOUT BERNIE SANDERS
RIGHT NOW AND I KNOW PEOPLE COME
TOGETHER ONCE A NOMINEE IS
PICKED BUT I HAVE A HARD TIME
IMAGINING HOW THESE PEOPLE COME
BACK AROUND AND SUPPORT
BERNIE SANDERS AFTER SOME OF THE
THINGS THEY HAVE SAID.
IT RAISES ANOTHER BIG QUESTION
FOR ME, WHERE IS BARACK OBAMA?
HE RISKS HAVING HIS ENTIRE
LEGACY BEING DESTROYED BY THIS
GUY WHETHER HE WINS OR HE LOSES
AND HE’S SITTING ON THE
SIDELINES -- I DON’T GET IT.
THE SIMILARITIES BETWEEN TRUMP
AND SANDERS IS THAT THEY BOTH
REVEAL THE DISSATISFACTION OF
REGULAR VOTERS WITH THEIR
PARTIES.
HUGE ANTIESTABLISHMENT FERVOR
AND I THINK IT’S REAL.